Надворі ще темно, а прихожани Свято-Іллінської церкви Московського Патріархату
що в Києві на Подолі,
вже поспішають на ранкову службу
Новину про Об’єднавчий собор
на якому ухвалили статут, назву та обрали предстоятеля єдиної Православної церкви України
тут не вітають
Як і те, що митрополит Онуфрій
предстоятель Московського патріархату в Україні
офіційно втратив свій титул митрополита Київського
Це людське, а ми про благодать Божу.
А благодать Божа тільки у Онуфрія
Яке має відношення Константинополь до України
я так само можу сказати
що квартира сусіда - це моя квартира,
і буду розпоряджатись нею
Ну, ми молимось за єдинство і мир
Я про це нічого не знаю, я не дивлюсь новини
Знімати у церкві нам не дозволили
Від коментарів священники відмовилися
Офіційна позиція церкви
Московського патріархату така
Константинополь не мав права змінювати
юрисдикцію Київської Метрополії
Тож усі наступні його рішення неканонічні
З'єднання церков має відбуватись
тільки на канонічній основі
якщо, наприклад, із-за розколу
Філарета відлучили від церкви
то він мав в церкву прийти через покаяння
але цього не відбулось
Це гординя, котра йому не дозволяє
прийти до цього рішення
Звичайно...
Хотілося б щоб всі молились разом, але поки що …
Тим часом релігійний мир охороняють і представники Нацгвардії,
щоб уникнути провокацій
біля церков Московського Патріархату
зокрема, і біля Свято-Іллінської церкви
Офіційно святкувати появу єдиної Православної церкви України
українці зможуть 6 січня
саме тоді, на Різдво, її новообраний предстоятель
митрополит Епіфаній отримає з рук Вселенського Патріарха Варфоломія
довгоочікуваний Томос
Тим часом Епіфанія,
Митрополита Київського і всієї України
вже визнав Константинополь
Його ім’я виголосили на літургії
у церкві Святого Миколая у Стамбулі
У Києві ж перша святкова літургія за участі митрополита Епіфанія
відбулась у Михайлівському Золотоверхому соборі
який стане кафедральним собором єдиної Православної церкви України
Для Митрополита це особливе місце,
тут він навчався
тут згодом прийняв чернечий постриг
і присвятив життя служінню Богу
Три гілки українського православ’я
зараз об’єднані в єдину
Українську православну Церкву
Але ще потрібно багато трудитись
для того, щоб ця церква була насправді єдиною
Тому я вже говорив про те
що ми запрошуємо всіх наших співбратів з Московського патріархату
до єдності, до єдиної помісної
української Православної церкви
На мирне об’єднання сподіваються
і парафіяни вже єдиної
Православної церкви України
Віталіна - викладачка Київської богословської академії
ректором якої є новообраний предстоятель церкви
І я думаю, що він як дипломат буде гарно спілкуватись
розширяти взаємозв'язки з багатьма церквами
і я думаю, що скоро до нас
приєднається дуже багато
і очільників, і людей, віруючих з Московського патріархату
Для багатьох українців
створення єдиної і незалежної
Православної церкви України
питання не лише релігійне, а й політичне
Канонічна церква, це, напевно, плюс для всіх віруючих людей
Ми огородились ще одним щитом
від Кремлівської агресії
Так що я, напевне, за
На наш народ прийшло таке Боже благословення
що нарешті об'єднаємось всі, що ми будемо разом
бо це Богу угодно
Єдине, що обєднує всіх вірян в Україні
це бажання зберегти мир - незалежно від того,
хто в якій церкві молиться.